well we're having a scene as you can say
to tell whether it's for real between
the two fighters this kind of thing is
and going on all along in terms of
promotion of a fight in this time it
seems to be for real because Joe Frazier
is really angry I think that Ali is
probably clowning and my wife's behind
him and look at the intense Sun makes a
lot of sense so how can I protect my
woman if I'm walking she she's
half-naked some sadist run up and grab
her hell I shouldn't put out there if I
got merchandise I'm gonna sell I put
them put in winter view to see so if I
want my wife
oh I don't want anybody to see my wife
what's private was mine everybody
looking at her it was me what's wrong
with it how can you have a wife somebody
you love anything God made pressures he
Nature has it you cannot find diamonds
either you have to dig and dig and dig
me got a verse to clean them you cannot
you cannot fight listen you did not find
gold everything got me value meaning
hard to get pearls rubies and a midol
you have to dig and have time you don't
strike everything God created that was
valuable he made it hard to get to a my
woman more important than some diamonds
and all some gold when she's a fear was
produced my sons and daughters
why should she walk around all nude in
all of these design clothes her breasts
out she's on the beach wearing clothes
that show more than her panties when
she's gonna be hit do you do have a
bodyguard you know you don't know one
bodyguard when he wishes to create a
thing
he just orders it to being it comes into
existence but this orders not convey the
words which takes a tumble all right
sound cares ears he hears the seeds
elves on the quiet thoughts he stops
those whose greedy's apiece how you guys
doing welcome to the dich I got a
special guest here with me Jonathan Ike
he's the critically acclaimed
best-selling author we're gonna get into
a story and then from the story let's
see I mean the picture might give it
away but uh Jonathan how are you I'm
good how are you thank you for being
with us on the Dean show thank you don't
go to the shot with the picture yet
we're gonna start off with a story from
your book yeah okay and then we're gonna
get into more from there it starts off
I'll start it off it was an elderly man
with his grandson right that's right and
he was looking for a famous individual
he ends up at his finally finding him
and what happens then tell us tell us
about the story you take off with it
this elderly man he's from Tanzania with
his grandson travels to the United
States they go to Chicago first knocking
on doors looking for Mohammed Ali
Mohammed oddly they can't find him in
Chicago they hear that he's moved to Los
Angeles they take a plane to Los Angeles
and they go riding around in a taxi
looking for a house that looks like
Ali's house they have a picture of Ali's
house from the newspaper and they find
the house they they go up knock on the
door and they're carrying a Big Mac in a
bag because you know they want to make
an offering a humble gesture of yeah you
don't arrive empty-handed yeah so this
this elderly man and his grandson knock
on the door
and all the answers and the old man says
we've come all the way from Africa we
were looking for Mohammed Ali I wanted
my son my grandson to meet the great
Muhammad Ali before he died
I want him to be able to say that he met
Muhammad Ali and Ali is this the
mid-1990s now he's you know he's been
out of the spotlight for a while he's
he's older he's has trouble walking he
he speaks very softly he murmurs and and
you know very softly hard to understand
was this around an 80s late 90 mid-90s
Midnight's before he lights the Olympic
torch so he was really in a period of
where he's not getting a lot of
attention he's little do it depressed to
be honest yeah but he welcomes this old
man and his grandson into the house he
makes them sandwiches he eats the Big
Mac and he actually he ate the Big Mac
like one bite and his manager Larry Kolb
was there with him and Larry's the one
who told me this story and hours go by
and Ali's entertaining them with stories
he's telling he's doing magic tricks for
them and then after a while does as it's
been most of the afternoon to get in the
car all the offers to drive them back to
the motel that they're staying at by the
by the airport so they piled into Ali's
Rolls Royce and they drive this older
man and his grandson to them to the
hotel and they they say goodbye they
give the hugs and handshakes and when
they're leaving they're driving back to
Ali's house Larry Kolb the manager turns
to Ali it says why why why did you spend
the whole day with those people you
could have just signed an autograph and
they would have been perfectly happy and
Ali said something that was really
remarkable he said I believe that
there's a tallying angel that there's an
angel who's counting all of your good
deeds and all of your bad deeds and I've
done a lot of bad things in my life I've
been not always a good husband not
always a good father I've made a lot of
mistakes and this is my time to make up
for those mistakes and to do more good
deeds so that I go to paradise because
he had a very vivid impression of what
hell was like and what paradise was like
and he really felt that he had work to
do in order to ensure his place in
paradise and and that's why he
he spent all that time with that with
that older man and with his grandson and
a very touching story he actually did he
had a vivid image in your book you
talked about he talks about the Hellfire
like the sizzling yeah he talking then
he thought I was like putting your head
on a frying pan he turned he for
millions of years yeah and but just to
take a timeout like that and he puts
them in his Rolls Royce and he takes
them - no he spends like he said the day
with them that's something just unheard
of you know you think about celebrities
and people you know time is money Yeah
right
I don't they don't have time for anyone
just really many people but many people
are egotistic narcissistic they don't
want to you know connect with with the
outside world but he connected I mean
you show that he couldn't say no to
anybody he loved it he fed off of it you
know a lot of people would say to him
you know he's a big famous guy comes to
your office for a business meeting or
something they'd say Mohammed we have a
car waiting for you in the back alley so
that you can get out of here quickly and
he'd say no no no pull it around to the
front I want the people to see me and
he'd spend an hour even if he would late
be late for his next appointment he'd
spend an hour on the street just playing
around with people he just he couldn't
get enough he loved people what was now
let's talk about you now for a minute
what what motivated you to write this
book this biography so many have been
written so many documentaries and now
the timing now what motivated you to to
put this together you know I was a kid
in the 70s I can remember rooting for
Ali
against George Foreman and Joe Frazier
and to me he was the greatest hero
because he was so different he was
outspoken he had political stands it
wasn't just about the sport he was about
something bigger and as a kid I didn't
fully appreciate that but I just knew
there was something magical about this
guy and the fact that he was black the
fact that he was a Muslim you know the
word Muslim mean one who submits and
talent to the will of God one who
submits and college of the will of God
that's what Muslim me was all again as a
kid to me just kind of strange stuff
that I didn't fully understand but when
when when it occurred to me that nobody
had yet written the full biography of
Ali there as you said they've been
documentaries there have been a lot of
books written about different aspects of
his life but nobody had done the full
biography and it's now 50 years since he
took his stand against
Vietnam War it's 50 years 53 years since
he changed his name from Cassius Clay to
Muhammad Ali and embraced Islam I
thought it was time and enough time had
gone by that you could really put some
of those events in historical
perspective and there were still enough
people around to talk to who were alive
back then who knew him including his
wives Ali was alive at the time I began
this work so it's just seemed like the
right time to do a big look at his life
were you there at his janazah his
funeral prayer do you yeah it was a in
his hometown I was in Louisville June
last year I was there was your book
already it was still you're still
writing it in the ending phases or I was
getting close to done at that point but
I still had some work to do so huh but I
had already spoken to most of the key
people in his life and saw them all down
there at the at the janazah service now
who are the key players in his life that
were still around today but some of them
that you actually got to spend some time
with well three of his four wives are
still living and three of them with you
know there was the first one was worse
one was Berlin it was San Jesus his
first wife when she passed away yeah in
the 80s but Belinda who later changed
her name to kalila she was the one let
me refresh that Herbert Muhammad
introduced introduced okay she was
raised in the Nation of Islam yes and
her parents were some of the very first
members of the Nation of Islam so she
was there's almost like an arranged
marriage the nation but she wasn't she
wasn't practicing or she didn't is that
sort the first one she didn't practice
yes she then Belinda Kalinda came she's
still around she's still our so you got
to spend some time a lot of time with
her yeah
as well as his third wife Veronica and
his current wife or his most recent wife
at the time of his death he was still
married to Lonnie yeah so I spent time
with all of them and there they're all
remarkable women and they obviously knew
him better than anybody yeah and then
you have how about some of these other
key players like Herbert Muhammad I
wouldn't do found of him now Herbert
passed away Oh God his son he was taken
his cart was 30 40 percent yeah a lot of
money from Ali but Ali still loved him
you know how they didn't care about
money yeah that was amazing I just let
it go
you know and he knew Herbert was taking
30 40 percent of everything and off the
top before taxes before expenses but
I'll he just didn't care all his life he
didn't really care about money he just
you know he said if people want to take
it from me they must need it yeah oh
really
some would say naive other people would
say amazing attitude
what fight was that where you had Don
King I'm not too funny may God help us
all you know is he still around
yeah don't you get did you get time with
him so I don't know
you know there's hope for everybody you
know until the end but he went there was
a situation I don't know it was a fight
that all he was supposed to get you talk
about this in your book he was supposed
to get six seven million correct me if
I'm wrong and then he only gave him so
much and there was like a million two
left something like that so he goes and
sends the guy with the notary gives him
fifty thousand right an ally just state
you know Holly signed a contract giving
Don King a million dollars in exchange
for fifty thousand dollars - a million
so he owes he's taking the cash fifty
thousand and saying I'll give you a
check for a million so he's basically
trading fifty thousand for a million and
yeah he knew it was stupid but he just
couldn't say no and Don King just you
know laughed all laugh all the way to
the bank so you got to collect a lot of
data a lot of information how did that
feel I mean going back you know to spend
time I would love to spend time you know
you some people who knew him the best
who's who who were there with him
through they were there from the
beginning right they having his brother
who you know his brother he was younger
his brother still around I spent a lot
of time with Rock'em on and you know
Rock'em on could tell you you know what
they had in the backyard what kind of
toys they had where the goldfish pond
was all this stuff you know what he took
me into their bedroom where they were
they were raised and told me you know
where the beds were positioned and you
know all these great details that you
can't really get if you wait another you
know 10 10 or 20 years to write this
book so it was it was a real thrill for
me to be able to walk in all these
footsteps a little bit and to see how he
lived and know the people who knew him
the best tell us a little about yourself
how long have you been what how long
have you had this passion for writing
when did you start and
and talk to us a little bit I've always
liked writing even from from you know
grade school days and I worked at my you
know school newspaper and then worked at
my hometown newspaper and then went to
college and studied journalism and
worked at newspapers and all over the
country and ended up at The Wall Street
Journal that was my most recent job and
then started writing for six years and
left there just to begin writing books
and I've been writing books for the last
15 years you did something also on Al
Capone yeah I wrote a book about Al
Capone yeah how long ago was that that
was 2010 I guess yeah it was really
about the case against Capone how the
government went about trying to get him
and in many cases had to you know
concoct evidence and yeah do all kinds
of sneaky things to put him away he how
did he just ask you about that
interesting he actually died Al Capone
of an ailment of an illness
if Allah syphilis right yeah yeah he
probably had it most of his adult life
and and could have been treated for it
early on but wasn't and as a result by
the time he went to prison it began to
affect his brain and he began to go mad
from from from the city was eating away
yeah and you you are you go over some
what some new statistics regarding Ali
Muhammad Ali's condition and you cite
something like two hundred thousand plus
hits that he took that's my best
estimate yeah what I did was I worked
with a company that does boxing
statistics and we actually counted every
punch that hit Ali over the course of
his career we we watched every round of
every fight Wow and we charted the punch
is not just how many but what kind of
punch they were so you actually said not
me ladies these guys from Compu box
every punt every punch every punch he he
threw and every punch that was thrown at
him yeah and we were able to see how
much damage he was taking how much
damage he was giving over the course of
his career and you could see that as he
gets older which you know to be expected
he begins slowing down and taking a lot
more punches
and in the second half of his career
he's taking more punches than he's
giving so what I did was I took those
numbers and I extrapolated them over the
course of his amateur career you know if
we know that he took for example you
know 13 punches per round on average
over the course of his career if you
extrapolate that for his amateur career
for sparring sessions for exhibitions my
estimate is that he took about two
hundred thousand punches over the course
of his career and it was it was said
that early in the early seventies is
when his family was starting to get
concerned about some of the the brain
damage that was happening is that
correct that's right they began to
notice that he was slurring his speech
that he was mumbling even if you go back
and you watch him on TV now go on
YouTube and just watch his interviews
over the years you can see it that over
the night course of the 70s he his voice
gets softer harder to understand and his
the words come more slowly and this was
a guy who was a brilliant brilliant
linguist I mean he was a fabulous
speaker and he was funny and he was
quick but you can it said you can watch
his his speech was deteriorating and
that's a sign of neurological damage but
he kept on for another another ten years
I kept fighting and even then you know
when he began to realize it there all
these interviews where he would ask
reporters do you think I'm getting
punched drunk do you think I'm getting
brain-damaged because people say that I
don't sound right so he was aware of it
but yeah the money was so good he was
being pushed by all these people around
him to keep fighting because they liked
having the money to they liked the
lifestyle it was hard to give up well
that shows I mean when we talked about
he his his genuine sincere love for
people like this Herbert and and what
role did
Arum is still around today right Bob I'm
still did you spend time with him yeah I
interviewed Bob a couple of times yeah
and some of the other key players I mean
well I mean this is just my opinion when
you really care for someone right when
money is not a top priority you want
what's best for him right you follow me
what you're talking about they like that
entourage they like the money the fame
everything and they're getting a part of
that and you really care for the man and
you're gonna put him really first and
maybe this wouldn't went to the extent
that it did
what do you yeah it's it's it's tough to
say because obviously responsibility
lies with Ali yeah primarily but if some
of the other people in his corner had
said I won't go I won't be a part of
this anymore I quit maybe it would have
gotten his attention I mean his mother
and father were saying quit but they
were still coming to his fights and
still cheering for him and you know his
his family maybe could have done more -
its represent all these people are you
know they're they're riding that train
they're taking that money and nobody
wants to see it in because they're never
gonna have easy money like that again I
was under I was getting the impression
that because he continued to fight he
wasn't all there and he wasn't able to
make those those those decisions as
someone who wasn't brain damaged the way
he was that's right it's a bit of a
catch-22 right because he is the brain
damage making his his judgment impaired
so that he can't decide whether to quit
or not or is it the other way around you
know it's really sad it may be that he
wasn't really in good enough shape
anymore to make those decisions for
himself and and a wife or a father or a
mother should have come in and said you
know no more there was his his trainer
and was a Di Angelo Angelo Dundee Angelo
Dundee he's he's passed away yes yes but
there was one fight when he find he
threw in the towel he stopped the fight
that was against was a home guest Larry
home Larry unfortunately it was you know
much too late it was it was late in his
career he was already 40 years old or 39
and it was also just late in that fight
he'd already taken a massive beam he
never should have been in the ring that
night at all mm-hmm we talked about him
now being able to say no right but there
was one man that you mentioned that he
said no - and it was Louis Farrakhan he
came to visit him and he was trying to
revive the nation right tell us about
that
yeah Farrakhan told me this story that
really amazed me because it you got to
spend time with him also and I thank you
everybody yeah they I'm very persistent
I hear I get people to talk to me so you
know Ali became a Muslim because of the
Nation of Islam because of Elijah
Muhammad yeah and it wasn't just the
religion it was it was race it was a big
part of it he you know he liked what it
had to say about being black in America
so when Elijah Muhammad died
Elijah's sons took the Nation of Islam
in a different direction eventually
broke it up and took their followers
into Orthodox Islam and Ali went along
and became a more traditional Muslim but
Minister Farrakhan decided he wanted to
try to rebuild the Nation of Islam and
restore the teachings of Elijah Muhammad
so he went to Muhammad Ali and said
brother Muhammad you know we did not
become Muslims because of the Quran we
became Muslims because of the teachings
of Elijah Muhammad I want to restore the
teachings I want to rebuild the Nation
of Islam and you know will you come with
me and the story that Farrakhan told me
is that they were in Ali's kitchen and
there was a football game on TV and Ali
said Farrakhan do you see that TV you
see that football game how many people
are in that Stadium and Ali said
everybody in that stadium knows me but
none of them know you get out I'm not
not coming with you I'm not I'm not
coming back to the Nation of Islam and
it was an interesting story because it
you know it doesn't really I think it's
just it was a very honest moment how
long because earlier in his career he
was afraid that they would kill him yeah
he left the nation that's right yeah he
was afraid of Elijah Muhammad Elijah
Muhammad you know as long as he was
alive was ran that organization with
with a lot of power and you know
obviously people felt like Malcolm X and
others who crossed Elijah Muhammad paid
for it and Ali mentioned a couple of
times that he was afraid if he ever left
that he might be assassinated yeah now
I've talked about I mean you use you
mentioned that towards more towards the
end of your book you talk about his
transition with Wallace D Muhammad so
that's a key point
that he I'm trying to figure out because
this was around what he was probably in
his late 30s know that he finally
accepted Islam real Islam what we call
it yeah around what yeah I would have
been the late 70s late 70s do you think
he was he was considering coming over to
Islam from the nation at that point when
he was scared that they would they were
going to kill him no I don't think so I
think it was it was Elijah Muhammad's
sons that that helped him guided him
toward real Islam yeah yeah so I've
interviewed many they have captains and
former ministers from from the nation
and we see a lot of the this transition
towards the end when him and Malcolm
also Malcolm ended up leaving the nation
and because I make this differentiation
and many people don't know that there's
you know as Orthodox Muslims we don't
you know consider this this is kind of
not real Islam you know I mean because
the teachings of real Islam when for
instance like what they originally
believed in white man's the devil is
that there's nothing to do that's like
you know worshipping a man you know real
Islam calls upon only worshipping the
Creator so anyone who many of these
people who study the real Islam they saw
that hold on this has nothing if you
just open up the Quran this has nothing
to do with the real teachings and they
end up making that transition but it's
interesting that I'm trying to figure
out at what point because he was scared
but Wallace D ended up bringing a lot of
people over and then what happens from
there Farrakhan visits him to try to
revive it but then he said no right he
was loyal to Wallace D and one of the
things that happened when Elijah died is
Herbert told Ali that my father wanted
you to listen to Wallace and to do
whatever Wallace says wait Herbert
Herbert is his Wallace's brother oh
that's his brother now okay the stones
of Elijah who which one is older I think
Herbert was the older Herbert was the
older okay so and it was Herbert who
said my father's we
wishes for you to follow his successor
hallo Wallace D and do whatever he told
his told whatever he says and Olli did
that and Wallace then began to
transition toward Orthodox Islam and Ali
followed him yeah but I don't think he
would have done that
prior to Elijah's - you talk about him
also with with with his friends and
colleagues people who were Muslim that
how he was he was inviting them to pray
I pray every morning at 5 o'clock my
clock rings at 4:30 I'm up at 5:00 I
take a shower and I put my white robe on
I put the towel on the floor and I face
the east towards Mecca and we say surely
I have turned myself to the o Allah
trying to be upright to him who has
originated in heavens and the earth and
I'm not of the polytheists surely my
prayers my sacrifice is my life and my
death are all for Allah the Lord of all
the world's no associate says he yes am
I commanded I am of those who submit or
are long thou art the king
thou art my Lord and I am dying servant
I have been greatly unjust to myself and
I do confess my fault so please grant me
protection against all my fault
fond on grants protection against faults
but thou and to lead me to the vestal
models for none can turn away from me
the worst of models but thee and got me
to the best of morals for none can guide
to the best of morals but the you taught
you discussed that in your book could
you talk about that and his his real
devotion and the solids that he found in
prayer another bath for another shower
will clean my mouth pray and at 5:00 in
the morning
this goes on if when I'm right now I
didn't do that for the first phrase to
fight nor the cipher snorting fight
really no sir
our head got big and I started thinking
it was my training camp and my boxing
ability they kept me where I was that
and God punished me and he gave me a
good whoopin he broke my jaw in the
sacrum fight and he got me whooped and
knocked down in the Frazier fight and I
realized I wasn't that great after all
so I had to get not only together
physically but spiritually for this
fight I've prayed
every day for five days five times a day
for the past of four months and
everything is perfect and if I lost with
me it ain't no way no man can win no
wait and these things that really this
is also towards at what point in his
life was this I think it was after he
retired from boxing and it began to
develop a real interest in studying the
Koran and studying Islam and and and
learning from from other teachers he
would go to the homes of famous Imams
and would study with them and just sit
at their table and and listen I'm and he
wasn't speaking as much because his
voice was was was was vanishing so he
really would just sit silently for hours
and listen and he would transcribe from
the Quran and transcribed from from from
speeches from from others that things
that he'd read books about Islam and
that's how he taught himself by
transcribing a lot of it because he was
not a great reader but if he transcribed
something into a notebook or onto a note
card his brain was would absorb it so he
liked to do that he also liked to copy
down the the contradictions in the
Christian Bible and point out all of the
things in there that couldn't be true
because it said something opposite in
one part of the Bible so he loved
gathering a bunch of Christians around
and always this for mothers and mother
how come is everything white I said why
is Jesus white with blond hair blue eyes
why is the Lord's Supper all white men
angels are like who Marian
ever even the Angels I said mother when
we died and you go to heaven she said
naturally we go to heaven I said what
happened all the black angels they took
some pictures so I choose to follow the
Islamic path because I've never saw so
much love I never saw so many people
hugging each other kissing each other
praying five times a day the women in
the lone garments the way that would eat
you can go to any country si Salaam
alaikum alaikum al-salam you got a home
you got a brother I chose the Islamic
path because they connected me as a
Christian in America I couldn't go to
the white churches as a Christian that
was for those people it did them good
didn't do me good and saying look at all
the mistakes that are in your Bible now
and then teaching them about the Quran
he really liked the idea of playing that
role of teacher and he would often you
know there be these sports fans who just
wanted to be around Ali and come back to
my hotel room in the next three hours
he'd be talking with them about the
Bible verses the Quran and you know bore
them to tears but but he he enjoyed that
I think it was important to him but the
word Muslim me one is the missin talent
to the will of God one who submits
ontology of the will of God that's a
Muslim mean so I I don't know I cannot
be the judge on how much I submit and
Tyler's the will of God God Himself can
only judges so I can't say how good I am
and no true Muslim will brag I even will
even take a chance on saying he's good
he's halfway good I'm not it's up to
Allah God to be the judge see you talked
about him being also a peacemaker going
to other parts of the world and calling
for this unity you know this because
obviously there's you know a great
misunderstanding about Islam today you
can't doubt it many politicians I've
exploited that fact but even at his time
it wasn't as obviously as bad I don't
think but he was talking to Americans
here about Islam encourages him to look
into it then he would go abroad and
visit different countries and you know
talk about you mentioned us in your book
yeah he would travel a lot throughout
the Muslim world in particular because
he was the best-known Muslim in America
and he would say that the Muslims need
to understand America and Americans need
to understand the Muslims better because
this is before 9/11 but there were still
these terrorist attacks you know in
there was the attack on the base in
Lebanon and there were all these you
know they were even before 9/11 there
was an image in some Americans mind the
prejudice that that Muslims were
terrorists and that was you know a
generic label that was applied and Ali
really wanted to to fight that so he
traveled around the world and and in
places that not a lot of Americans went
you know he went to Pakistan and
Afghanistan and
gave these lectures about the importance
of trying to build bridges between the
two societies and the two religions yeah
how was how did how did that shift
happen when at a time
how was he foreseen by the American
public when he refused to go into the
war and how that all changed
I mean went from being someone who I
mean was he he was like despised wasn't
he no it was absolutely the most
I believe the most hated man in America
that most hated most hated man in
America during the late 60s when he
refused to fight in Vietnam and
announced his allegiance with the Nation
of Islam which the FBI considered a
terrorist cult and he was stripped of
his boxing license he couldn't work he
couldn't travel outside the country and
that only began to change over time and
a couple things happen one is the
Vietnam War became terribly unpopular
and people realized that that he had a
point in opposing it and they also began
to believe that he was at least
legitimate in his religious beliefs that
he wasn't faking it you know whether you
like the Nation of Islam or not you had
to admit the guy was was loyal and truly
believed or else he wouldn't have given
up three and a half years of his career
and millions of dollars to stand up for
his religious beliefs and then later by
the 90s and he becomes a much more
beloved figure in part because he's been
silenced by this disease by my
Parkinson's
he doesn't talk as much so he just
becomes kind of like a teddy bear we all
want to hug him and and love him and
then he goes around giving these
speeches about religious tolerance and
and he becomes a much more just you know
figure that we can all appreciate more
mm-hmm
well what another thing that inspires me
and there's it shows that the earlier
part of his life and it's like anyone
who's it's hard to fame opens up a whole
another world of temptation and
corruption and all these things that you
know tantalite are calling you I didn't
you get susceptible to that and some
people can't overcome it and some people
they drown themselves and in all the
things that come with it right
and there's that part of his life but
then it just shows that you know a
person who had you know no man's perfect
you know you make mistakes and in the
earlier part of his life you know you
can see where and it goes with that
story where he admits you know I've done
some bad things but then it shows you
know the that he really relied on the
mercy of God and he was really spending
the latter part of his life because it
didn't he didn't he didn't talk about
that he truly started become a man until
he's like late what was it late 30s
that he finally matured mm-hmm right and
then he started to really change his
life and start to be a humanitarian and
and and give back that's right and he
said often that you know this disease in
many ways may have been a gift because
it forced him to slow down it forced
people to look at him differently and to
say you know he was the greatest the
fastest the strongest the prettiest and
now look he's he's trembling he can't
speak but he was never ashamed of it he
stood up there in public and let people
see him that way my grateful too for
your career
all of us is this a potential hey and he
said I want people to see me this way
because they'll know that we're all
human and it'll help other people to
deal with their problems so he was in
some ways you know he was the biggest
egotist of all time but in some ways he
was really humble and really believed
that he was no snow - no different from
anybody else so after speaking to all
these countless you know array of
different people people who were you
know there from the beginning how did it
leave you off you know the feeling you
know the it's like you you know him
better now then then you know that yeah
I know better than you know I know some
of my own family yeah it's funny because
there were times when I and this happens
with your own family - there were times
where I was just so mad at him and how
could you behave that way how could you
be so stupid how could you say such a
thing but he always won me over again he
always came back and did something to
charm me and to make me feel like he was
a good person in the end and it's
complicated any time you devote four
years of your life or more to diving
into another person's life there's gonna
be some stuff that disturbs you but
overall I felt like you know I that I
loved the guy so so that took you you
said for four years - yeah a little more
than the four years wow that's that's
you know that's a full-time job
you know dedicated for year people go to
college for that because right yeah this
is more in these four years Wow I got a
degree in Muhammad Ali yeah so your your
book now is is titled Ali and this is
gonna be where can people get the book
it goes on sale October 3rd it'll be on
Amazon and all the bookstores
independent neighborhood bookstores
should all have it that I hope people
will check it out and those an audiobook
and in the e-book too so it should be
easy to find you're gonna have it on
inaudible yes yeah are you the one
that's uh they got a real actor to do it
somebody better than me yeah
well Jonathan I appreciate you spending
the time with us here in the Dean show
and I'm sharing some of these insights
from his life hopefully we get there was
a lot to cover hopefully God woman we
can have you back I know there's a lot
more to talk about you know anytime it's
a big book but we had a short amount of
time
god bless you thank you very much thank
you and thank you guys for tuning in
Jonathan with his new book ollie and
make sure you check it out and we'll see
you next time here in addy show until
then peace be with you Sonic
what's the best thing on me get ready to
meet God
owning a real estate learning business
teaching boxes that won't get me to
heaven God is watching me God is God
don't praise me because I beat Joe
Frazier I don't care about being America
as far as real wealth that's all he is
he wants to know how do we treat each
other how do we help each other so I'm
gonna dedicate my life to using my name
in popularity and helping charities
helping people you name people bringing
people bumming each other because the
religious believes we need somebody in
the world to help us uh make peace so
when I die if there's a heaven I want to
see it because we live how long 80 years
the odds are everybody in this room some
of you will be dead 20 years from now
some of you will be dead 50 years ago
some of them be dead 30 is someone we
dare 60 70 years we all want to die a
soul soul this is a test to see where
will we spend our life and have them
help this is not the life now your real
self is inside you your body gets old
look at the freak little euro teeth your
hair is leaving you your bodies get
tired but your soul and your spirit
never dies
that's what live ever so your body it's
just housing your soul in spirit
so God is testing us on how we treat
each other that we live to see where our
real home be and heaven
so this physical stuff don't last is so
low so my car this building is gonna be
here when the man who built a dam
there'd been many kings and queens of
England they're all dead
after this one is gone another to come
so we don't stay here we're just
trustees we don't own nothing even your
children are not yours if you think I'm
laughs your wife is not yours you don't
own your children you know and your
family so what am I saying the most
important thing about life is what's
gonna happen when you die are you gonna
go to have on the hill and that's
eternity
how long is eternity so what am I gonna
do it I'm through fighting I have 16
years believe the doctor get myself
ready to meet God and go to the best
place what they make sense thank you
[Music]